Dean so you're single are you looking
for love all the wrong places
I don't know are we all not ever just
looking for love does that make any
sense at all oh really I just moved out
of my house I'm just like trying to
travel the country and see what happens
god you're hot like where are you living
I moved out of my house I live in a van
now downs Dean by the river with the
beanie in the long hairs I'm just trying
to complete the aesthetic here I'm just
I'm planning on traveling all across the
content of the US and then like maybe up
into Canada as well so I don't know if
that's very conducive for a relationship
if it does happen great but if not then
I'm not willing to you know fight it I
guess what inspired the living in the
van yeah I think I saw free soul Alex
Honnold really just he just made me want
to do it and give it a go I don't know I
just have always kind of had like a
nomadic spirit in me and I've always
wanted to do it and I was like no better
time than now I'm single and unemployed
and now I'm homeless and so I might as
well do it you know want to date this
guy he's real really selling Dean angler
Dan wells Adams sharing likes updates
with et at Wango Tango on your podcast
you recently talked about why your
parents have not met Sara's parents and
that they'll meet for the first time at
the wedding yeah I said it in tow like
it was a total joke bit you know that
like they have different political views
and like the rule was that they weren't
allowed to talk politics at the wedding
which i think is a normal rule at most
family gatherings I said it like as a
joke in total passing and then of course
it turned in like this whole thing you
know when everywhere yeah I know and so
I learned I learned was a hard thing to
convey on the Internet
yeah I know so I learned my lesson and
I'm not gonna talk about my family
anymore my parents upset that you said
my dad was confused
just cuz he's just like from an older
generation that's like wait what and my
mom thought it was funny cuz she was
like yeah no politics I don't want it to
be awkward so whatever that's show
business people did that mean the
proposals coming soon since you
mentioned the wedding oh I don't know if
I would jump to that conclusion it was
more of like I was talking to brandy
about her parents meeting her new
boyfriend's family and then she asked me
back and I was like the only way it's
happening is that away and that's that's
how it came across but her new boyfriend
oh I'm not allowed to tell that bachelor
nation no he's not but he is a very
good-looking man I've seen pictures of
it iris sister they killin it Billy
Ray's killing it
little nas ex Old Town Road it's number
one built Miley's probably gonna top her
up top him next week which would be
super dope the guys also have a lot to
say about this season of The
Bachelorette and seem up for returning
to bachelor in paradise are we gonna see
you guys back on bachelor in paradise
you as the bartender you possibly
looking for them oh man I don't know
that's a great question I mean you know
what is the thing the food there's great
what's the month in Mexico gonna do for
me negatively I guess the question it's
like you know I love yeah that'd be
great
why not you know America could get
really mad at you again it's like I've
already hit rock bottom so how much
further could I really go and there's a
good chance that Luke's gonna be there
right so you know actually I don't know
if he's gonna be there and I said I like
a nice strong
you know are you going back we're gonna
see you behind the bar maybe who knows I
mean it's always a fun gig it's always
nice to have a front row seat to watch
that that barn burned down you describe
you guys been watching this season I
have have you been watching I've watched
every episode have you yeah good have
you been watching you guys think of the
loop stuff seems a little overbearing
these hearts that he start to root for I
would say yeah but be passionate gotta
give him credit for that you look good
[Laughter]
thank you guys so much as always good to
see you have fun tonight
[Music]